「量子情報と計算の理解」へようこそ。私はJohn Watusで、教育担当テクニカルディレクターだ。
IBMQuantumに在籍している。これはシリーズの第9回目のレッスンで、量子情報の一般的な
定式化をテーマとした第3ユニットの最初のレッスンだ。これまでは量子情報の簡略的な定式化を使ってきた。
その定式化では、量子状態はユークリッドノルムが
1に等しい複素ベクトルで表される。一方、量子情報の一般的な定式化では、量子状態は
密度行列と呼ばれる特定の種類の行列で表される。このユニットの最初のレッスンは密度行列に焦点を当てており、
レッスンが進むにつれてその正体と仕組みを説明していく。密度行列は非常に
有用で、これから説明するさまざまな利点がある。密度行列を使えば、
量子状態ベクトルで表せるよりも広いクラスの状態を表現できる。たとえばノイズの影響を受けたシステムの状態や、量子状態の
ランダムな選択も含まれる。また、Bloch球についても見ていく。Bloch球はqubitの状態を考えるための非常に
わかりやすい幾何学的な方法を提供するもので、密度行列とどのようにつながるかも見ていく。
そのつながりはパウリ行列を通じた非常に注目すべき方法で実現される。最後に、複数の
システムの文脈での密度行列について説明する。特に、他のシステムと
相関している場合でも、孤立して見たシステムの量子状態をどう記述できるかを見ていく。他のシステムと絡み合っている可能性も含めてだ。これは重要なことで、
量子情報の簡略的な定式化の中では簡単にはできない。ここでレッスンの概要を示す。
まず密度行列の基礎として、関連する定義といくつかの例を取り上げ、
量子状態ベクトルとの関係についても説明する。次に密度行列の凸結合、つまり
密度行列の加重平均を取るとどうなるかについて話す。まず特定の
例として、いわゆる完全混合状態から始める。古典的な確率的状態が密度行列の
特殊なケースとして見られることを示し、線形代数のスペクトル定理がどのように関わるかについても説明する。
レッスンの第3部はBloch球に関するもので、レッスン冒頭で述べたように、
単一のqubitの状態を幾何学的に見る方法を提供する。レッスンの第4部では、密度行列が複数の
システムに対してどのように機能するかを説明する。積状態や、絡み合い状態を含むさまざまな種類の相関状態について論じ、
縮約状態の概念も取り上げる。縮約状態とは、複合システムの孤立した部分の状態を密度行列で記述したものだ。
これは偏微分トレースと呼ばれる演算を使って計算できる。レッスンの技術的な内容に入る前に、
密度行列を使う動機を説明するためにほんの少しだけ時間を取りたい。密度行列を使わない量子情報の簡略的な
定式化を使えば、Shorの因数分解アルゴリズムのような量子アルゴリズムを
何の困難もなく記述できる。では、なぜわざわざ密度行列を使うのか。
あるいは量子情報のこの一般的な定式化が必要なのか。理由はいくつかある。まず、密度行列は
量子状態ベクトルよりも広いクラスの量子状態を表現できる。不確かさや
ランダム性を含む量子状態も含めてだ。これは量子計算におけるノイズの影響をモデル化したい場合に重要で、
たとえばそういったケースだ。第2に、密度行列を使えば、複合システムの孤立した部分の量子状態を記述できる。
他のシステムと絡み合っているシステムの状態など、一時的に無視することを選んだ場合も含めて。レッスンの冒頭で述べたように、
これは量子情報の簡略的な定式化の中では簡単にも自然にもできない。
第3の理由は、密度行列を使うと古典的な情報が実際に
特殊なケースとして現れてくることだ。つまり、確率的状態とそれに対する演算の
本質的なアナロジーと、量子状態ベクトルとユニタリ演算のアナロジーを持つ代わりに、量子と古典の情報が
単一の数学的フレームワークの中で一緒に記述される。これは量子情報の数学的研究には
ほぼ不可欠だ。だから量子情報を数学的なレベルで真剣に理解したいなら、
密度行列について学ぶことを強く勧める。では密度行列の定義から始めよう。
定義のために、Xがシステムでsigmaがその古典的な状態集合だと仮定しよう。そして
その用語を使う際の前提として、Sigmaは有限かつ非空だということを思い出してほしい。いつものように
好みに応じて別の名前を使うこともできる。システムXの状態を記述する密度行列は、複素
数の要素を持つ行列で、その行と列は古典的な状態集合に対応している。明確に言うと、
行と列は同時に同じ対応関係を持つ。つまり密度行列は
常に正方行列だ。正方であることに加えて、満たさなければならないいくつかの条件がある。
それについては後で説明する。密度行列を表すのに特定の小文字のギリシャ文字がよく使われる。
rhoが最初の選択肢であることが多く、他によく使われるのは画面に示されている小文字のsigmaやtauだ。
これは単なる慣習だが、いつものようにこういった慣習は物事を
より認識しやすくするので役立つ。では密度行列が満たさなければならない条件、つまり
有効な密度行列であるための要件について話そう。条件は2つあって、まずそれらを列挙してから
何を意味するのかをより詳しく説明する。最初の条件は、密度行列は
単位トレースを持たなければならない、つまりトレースが1に等しくなければならないということだ。第2の条件は、
密度行列は半正定値でなければならないということだ。どちらの場合も、画面に表示されている
2つの条件を表す簡潔な記号的表現がある。では2つの条件をより詳しく説明しよう。
最初の条件はトレースに関するもので、これはすべての正方行列に対して定義された非常に重要な関数だ。
トレースは単に対角要素の和で、それを明示した方程式を示す。
トレースについては言うべきことがたくさんあって、なぜ重要なのかもあるが、今はその非常に基本的な
性質の一つだけに注目しよう。それは線形関数だということだ。トレースの他の性質は出てきたときに説明する。
密度行列に焦点を当てるために、第2の要件に進もう。その要件は
密度行列が半正定値であるということだ。これも多くの場面で現れる重要な概念で、
物理学、化学、最適化、機械学習など様々な分野に関係していて、いくつかの異なるが
同等な方法で表現できる。一つの表現方法として、行列rowが正半定値であるとは、行列Mが存在して
rowがMダガーとMの積に等しいということだ。そしてMそのものが
正方行列であることを要求しても、その制約を外しても変わらないことがわかる。行列rowが正半定値であることの別の表現方法は
rowがエルミートであるということで、つまりrowは自身の共役転置に等しく、すべての
固有値が非負の実数であるということだ。一般にエルミート行列は
実数の固有値しか持てないが、それは負にもなりうる。しかし固有値がどれも
負にはなれないという追加の制約を加えると、正半定値行列が得られる。ちなみに、ある行列が
正半定値かどうか知りたい場合は、この特徴付けを使って判定できる。行列がエルミートかどうかは非常に簡単に
確認できる——目で見ればわかる。固有値の計算はより難しいが、
コンピュータで行うのはそれほど難しくない。非常に効率的なアルゴリズムがあるからだ。
最後にもう一つ紹介する特徴付けは（他にもあるが）、rowの行数および列数と同じ数の成分を持つすべての列ベクトルsに対して
画面に表示されている不等式が成り立つということだ。言葉で言えば、sダガーとrowとsの積は非負の実数
でなければならない。これらの特徴付けがすべて同値であることは自明ではないが、実際そうだ。また明示しておくと、
行列rowが正半定値であることを示すのに一般的に使われる記法はrowが
0以上に見えるものだが、これは単なる省略記法であり、文字通りrowが0より大きいか
等しいという意味ではない。rowは行列だからそれは意味をなさない。また、
rowの各成分が0以上であるという意味でもない。特に、
成分がすべて非負でない正半定値行列も存在するし、成分がすべて非負でも
正半定値でない行列も存在する。この記法の背後にある考え方は、正半定値
行列が非負実数の行列版のようなものだということだ。しかしこれは単なる記法であり、その意味は
すでに説明した通りだ。では、いくつかの例を見てみよう。まず
正半定値行列の例から始める。実は、正半定値行列の例をランダムに生成するのは非常に簡単で、
適当に行列Mを選んで、MダガーとMを
計算するだけでいい。例えば、これが特に特別でない行列Mで、実際
この行列はランダムに生成したものだ——各成分の実部と虚部を独立に-9から+9の整数から選んで
生成した。だからここに見えるパターンや構造は純粋に偶然だ。
MにMの共役転置を掛けると、この行列が得られる。これは
正半定値だ。もちろん、ランダムな例から得られる洞察には限りがあるが、
より一般的な正半定値行列に共通のいくつかの特徴を示している。特に
対角成分、つまり左上から右下への対角線上の成分がすべて非負の実数であることに気づくだろう。
さらに、非対角成分は対応する対角
成分と比べて大きすぎない——つまり、注目している非対角成分と同じ行にある対角成分と同じ列にある対角成分と比べて。
しかしそれ以上のことがあり、正半定値であることは
行列全体の性質であって、個々の成分に対する条件ではないと認識することが重要だ。これが
正半定値行列の例だ。同様の方法で他の例も簡単に生成できる。
では次に、密度行列の例をいくつか見てみよう。密度行列では正半定値条件に加えてトレースが
1に等しいという条件も持つ。2×2の密度行列の例をいくつか示す。トレースは
4つのケースすべてで1に等しく、これらはエルミート行列でもある。だから前述の正半定値行列の2番目の特徴付けを使えば
残りは固有値がすべて非負であることを確認するだけだ。
確認したければそれはあなたに任せる。2×2行列の場合、手で固有値を計算するのはそれほど難しくない。
もちろんコンピュータに任せてもいい。例えば、線形代数の
Pythonパッケージにあるeigvals関数を使える。また、ゼロでない
正半定値行列をトレースで割ることで密度行列を得ることもできる。例えば、これが
少し前に見た例をそのトレースで割って得られる密度行列だ。このようにトレースで割ると
正半定値の性質は常に保たれ、トレースが線形関数であるという事実から
トレースが1の行列が確実に得られる。これはあくまでも例の小さなコレクションで、
レッスンが続くにつれてさらに多くの例が出てくる。次に少し時間をとって、密度行列の解釈、すなわち
直感的な意味について説明する。
まず認識しておくべきことは、ベクトルではなく行列で系の状態を表すのは少し変に思えるかもしれないということだ。対照的に、
量子情報の簡略化された定式化では、状態を表すのにベクトルを使い、行列、具体的にはユニタリ行列は
作用や操作を表す。これは数学がそうなっているだけで、
行列を線形写像として考えることは常にできるが、与えられた密度行列に関連する線形写像に
直感的な意味を直接結びつけることは通常しない。とはいえ、密度行列が実際に行列であるという事実は
非常に重要な側面であることがわかる。これについてはこの先見ていく。しかし今は一つだけ例を簡単に挙げると、密度行列の固有値は
非常に重要で、その状態に固有のランダム性や不確実性がどれだけあるかを
記述するからだ。密度行列を直感的なレベルで考える別の方法は
これらの行列の成分に注目することだ。密度行列の行と列は
扱っている系の古典的な状態と対応している。だから各成分に対して
対応する古典的な状態が一つある。密度行列の行と列は
扱っているどんな系の古典的な状態とも対応しているので、各成分に対して一つの
そのエントリの行に対応する古典的な状態が一つ、列に対応する古典的な状態が一つある
対角エントリの場合、その二つの古典的な状態は同じ状態だ。だから対角エントリは
特別なんだ。対角エントリの解釈の一つは、それらが確率だということで、具体的には
対応する古典的な状態が標準基底測定を行ったときに現れる確率だ
記述しているQuantum Stateを持つ系に対して。一方、非対角エントリについては、行に対応する古典的な状態が一つ
そのエントリの列に対応する異なる古典的な状態が一つある。非常に大雑把に言えば
これらのエントリは、この二つの古典的な状態がQuantum重ね合わせにある度合い、そして
それらの間の相対位相を表している。レッスンが進んでより多くの
具体的な例を見ていけば、より明確になるだろう。この時点では詳細が不明確かもしれないが、それは気にしなくていい
これはかなり大雑把な話で、頭の片隅に置いておくための
直感的なアイデアに過ぎない。次に、密度行列とQuantum State ベクトルの関係を見ていく。Quantum State ベクトルとは列
ベクトルでユークリッドノルムが1に等しいものだ。数学的定義を思い出すために、
ある特定の系の状態を表すQuantum State Vector sがあるとすると、同じ
Quantum stateを表す密度行列は、|ψ⟩⟨ψ|で与えられる。スクリーンに表示されているとおりだ。明確にすると、ψの添字は
何らかの形で扱っている系の古典的な状態に対応していて、それは密度行列の行と列と
系の古典的な状態の間の対応と全く同じだ。系にn個の
古典的な状態があり、列ベクトルと行ベクトルを行列として考えると、|ψ⟩はN×1行列だ
そして⟨ψ|は1×N行列だ。掛け算を行うとN×Nの
行列が得られる。これはその形から常に半正定値行列になる。また、トレースも
sが単位ベクトルであることから1に等しくなる。これについては後で
詳しく見ていく。この形の密度行列で表されるQuantum stateは純粋
状態と呼ばれる。いくつか例を挙げよう。まず、この状態を考えてみよう
これはプラス状態に似ているが、古典的な状態1に対応するエントリが
虚数だ。共役転置を計算すると、iの複素共役は
-iなのでマイナス符号が付く。掛け算をすると、スクリーンに示されている行列が得られる。すぐに
見てわかるようにエルミートだ。固有値は1と
0なので、半正定値で、トレースは1に等しい。だから密度行列だ
予想通りだ。標準基底とプラスマイナス基底に対応する密度行列も同様に計算できる。それらの密度行列は
ここに示されている。もう一つQuantum State Vectorの例がある。これは
シリーズの最初のレッスンの中で登場したものだ。共役転置を計算して掛け算を行うと
ここに示されている密度行列が得られる。やはりエルミートで
トレースは1に等しい。固有値を計算すると、やはり固有値が1のものと
0のものが一つずつある。ちなみに、それは全ての純粋状態に共通の特徴だ。常に固有値が1のものが一つあって
残りの固有値はすべて0だ。一般的に、完全に任意のQuantum State
Vector sに対して、エントリ数がいくつであっても、|ψ⟩に⟨ψ|を掛けると
このような形の密度行列が得られる。特に注目してほしいのは、対角エントリは常に
sのエントリとその複素共役を掛け合わせたもの、つまりそのエントリの絶対値の二乗だということだ。これが
トレースが常に1に等しくなることを確認する一つの方法だ。レッスンの前半で述べた
密度行列の対角エントリが、各古典的な状態が観測される確率を表しているという話とも一致している
標準基底測定を行った場合に。最後にもう一つ言及しておこう
密度行列ではグローバル位相に関する問題は生じない。二つのQuantum stateは、その密度
行列が等しい場合にのみ同一だ。特に、二つのQuantum State Vector sとφが
グローバル位相を除いて等しい、つまり一方、例えばφを、もう一方に
単位円上の複素数を掛けたものとして表せるとしよう。φの密度行列表現を計算すると
グローバル位相因子がその複素共役と掛け合わされ、1になることがわかる。つまり
事実上消えてしまい、sから得られるものと全く同じ密度行列が残る。ちょっとした
ボーナスだ。より一般的に言えば、密度行列を使う場合は、グローバル位相を除いた同値性に関する問題は全く生じない
これはQuantum State vectorsを使って量子状態を表現する場合に存在する縮退に過ぎない
密度行列でなく。密度行列は重要な性質を持っていて、それは凸
密度行列の組み合わせが量子状態の確率的または確率的な選択を表すということだ
別の言い方をすれば、密度行列は意味のある形で平均化できる。これは
Quantum State vectorsではできないことだ。これをより詳しく説明するために、まず
ある系のQuantum stateを表す二つの密度行列ρとσがある状況から始めよう。
0から1の間のpに対して、系が確率pでρの状態に準備されるとしよう。それ以外の場合は
系はσの状態に準備される。例えばpが1/2とすると
誰かがコインを投げて、表が出たら系をρの状態にする処理を行い
裏が出たら系をσの状態にする別の処理を行うようなイメージだ
今問題なのは、系の状態が何かということだ。明確にしておくと
系の状態について、どの準備が行われたかについての他の情報を無視して、単独で考えている
例えば、コインや状態準備を行った人の
記憶にアクセスできないとしよう。その問いへの答えは、二つの密度行列の加重平均に過ぎない
行列 P * ρ + 1 - P * σ、これはちなみに完全に
ρとσが密度行列でなく確率ベクトルだった場合と類似してる
確率的な状態を表すものとね。だからこれは衝撃的でも神秘的でもなく、むしろ
確率論でおなじみのものだ。確率を計算したり考えたりするとき、こういう平均化はいつもやってる
古典的なランダム選択についてね。そしてポイントは、これが密度行列にも機能するってことだ。ただし
量子状態ベクトルには機能しない。つまり、一般に二つの量子状態
ベクトルをこうやって平均してみても、有効な量子状態ベクトルは得られない。試してみると、たいてい
ユークリッドノルムが1にならないベクトルになる。しかし密度行列なら、こういう重み付き平均は常に
有効な密度行列になる。そしてより重要なのは、得られた密度行列がそのランダム選択を
意味のある形で表現するってことだ。これは選択肢が2つ以上のランダム選択にも一般化できる
特に、M個の密度行列とM個のエントリを持つ確率ベクトルがあって
それぞれの密度行列に対応する確率で系が各状態に準備されるなら
それらの密度行列の重み付き平均が系の結果状態を記述する。ちなみに
密度行列の凸結合と言うとき、これがその意味だ。凸結合とは単に、係数が確率ベクトルをなす線形
結合のことだ。これは常に密度行列になる
そして数学的に簡潔に言うなら、全ての密度行列の集合は
与えられた系に対して凸集合をなす。例えばM個の量子状態
ベクトル s0からsM-1と、確率p0からpm-1があってそれらが確率ベクトルをなすとき
系が各kについて確率PKで状態skに準備されるなら
系の結果状態は今画面に表示されてる密度行列で記述される。特に、量子状態ベクトルを直接平均するのではなく
対応する密度行列同士を平均してる
一般に、こういう状態は単一の量子状態
ベクトルとしては表現できない。例外は、全ての量子状態ベクトルがグローバル位相を除いて等価だとか、一つ以外の確率が全てゼロだとかいう自明な場合だ
こういうプロセスから純粋な量子状態は得られない。得られるのはいわゆる
混合量子状態で、そこには固有の不確かさが伴う。簡単な
例を見てみよう。qubitがあって、確率1/2でゼロ状態に準備され、そうでなければ
プラス状態に準備されるとする。ここに、説明した通りに平均して得られる密度行列がある
二つの可能な状態に対応する密度行列を計算し、対応する確率を掛けて足し合わせる
得られるのは確かに密度行列だ。エルミートで、トレースが1に等しい
この行列の固有値を計算すると、二つの正の実数が得られる。それはたぶんもうおなじみの二つの数で
cos²(π/8)とsin²(π/8)、つまり約0.85と
0.15だ。この状態には単一の量子状態ベクトル表現が存在しない。純粋状態じゃないわけだ。次に、一つの
特定の密度行列を見てみよう。それは単一のqubitの量子状態として、完全混合
状態と呼ばれるものを表す。この状態はよく出てくるから名前があると便利だし、密度行列の
重要な特徴を示す良い例でもある。実は、どんな系にも同様に定義された完全混合状態があるが
今は単純にするため、単一qubitのこの状態に集中しよう
qubitの状態をゼロ状態か1状態のどちらかにランダムに設定するとして、それぞれの確率は
1/2だ。一様ランダムビットと同じようなものだ。この密度行列表現は
通常の方法で計算できる。二つの状態の密度行列表現の平均を取る。これが
行列形式でどう見えるかだ。得られるのは単位行列を
2で割ったものだ。この状態を完全混合状態という。基本的には
qubitについての完全あるいは最大の不確かさを表す。ちょうど一様確率ベクトルが古典的確率の設定で最大の不確かさを表すように
一般に任意の系について、完全混合状態とは
標準基底状態を一様に選ぶことで得られる状態で、密度行列表現は
単位行列を次元数、あるいは等価的にその系の古典的状態の数で割ったものだ
今は単なる用語だが、設定を少し変えると密度行列の重要な特徴が見えてくる
特に、手順を変えて
ゼロと1の標準基底状態の代わりにプラスとマイナス状態に置き換えるとしよう。今度は画面に表示されてる
式から始めるが、計算を進めると全く同じ
密度行列が得られる。単位行列を2で割ったものだ。つまり前と同じ状態だ。
完全混合状態だ。これはよく言うように、バグじゃなくて仕様だ。二つの手順は実際に
異なるが、得られたqubitしか手元にないなら、物理的に区別する方法は全くない
統計的にも区別できない。例えば、このqubitに標準基底測定を行うとして
最初の手順が行われた後なら、結果ゼロが確率1/2で、結果1が確率1/2で得られるのは明らか。でも
二番目の手順でも全く同じ確率になる。そして他のどんなテストをしても同じだ
qubit自体だけをテストしてる限りはね。一般に密度行列は系がどう準備されたかを記述しない
その系に今後何かをした場合に何が起こるかを教えてくれるだけだ。操作を行うにしても
測定を行うにしても。実際、密度行列はこの点で完璧だ
二つの異なる手順が同じ密度行列になるなら、区別できない。統計的にも
区別できない。でも二つの密度行列が異なるなら、区別する方法がある。必ずしも確実にではないが
統計的にはね。量子の一般定式化を使うとき
古典的な情報は本質的に特殊なケースとして出てくる——今からその仕組みを説明する
具体的には、確率的な状態が密度
行列でどう表現されるかを見ていく。まず古典的な状態から始めよう。簡単な
例として、ここに1つのqubitの0と1という標準基底状態の密度行列表現がある
これらの状態を古典的な状態0と1に対応させると、これらの密度行列を
それらの状態を表すものと考えられる。非常にシンプルで、簡単に一般化できる
古典的な状態集合がΣであるシステムがあれば、古典的な状態aは、あるいは
密度行列 |a⟩⟨a| に対応する。その行列は、古典的な状態aに対応する行と列の
対角要素に1が1つあって、その他の要素は
全部ゼロだ。確率的な状態はこの形の行列の凸結合で表現される。これは自然なことで
密度行列の働きについて知っていることと合致している——具体的には、密度行列の凸結合は量子状態のランダムな、あるいは
確率的な選択を表すということだ。例えば、
古典的な状態集合が0からn-1の整数を含むシステムXがあるとしよう。ある正の整数nに対して
古典的な状態集合がこの形だと仮定しても、一般性はほとんど失われない。もし
別の古典的な状態集合があっても、単に古典的な状態をこのように名前を付け替えればいい。そして、
古典的な状態集合がこのような形をしていると仮定するのは便利なことが多い。主な理由は、
ベクトルと行列を使って明示的に書きやすくなるからだ。システムXの確率的な状態があって
通常の確率ベクトルで表現されているとすると、この確率的な状態を密度
行列に対応させられる。画面に示されているように、対応する密度行列の加重平均を取る
異なる古典的な状態に対応するものを。すると対角の密度行列が得られる。特に、確率が
この行列の対角に並んでいて、その他の要素は全部ゼロだ。もちろんこれは密度行列で
そうなるはずだと分かっているが、直接的に推論することもできる。エルミート行列で、そのトレースは
確率の和が1になるので1に等しい。対角行列の場合、固有値は対角
要素であって、確率だから全部非負だ。また、
対角の密度行列——つまり対角外の要素が全部ゼロのもの——は全部こういう形をしているはずだ。つまり要するに
確率的な状態は対角の密度行列に対応させられる。ちなみにこれは、
このレッスンの冒頭で述べた密度行列の要素についての非公式な解釈と一致している。特に、何も
量子重ね合わせにない——ここでは基本的に古典的なランダム性だけがある。対応して、対角外の
要素は全部ゼロだ。このシリーズの以前に、スペクトル定理について議論した
位相推定の文脈で、特にユニタリ行列に対して。スペクトル定理はそれより
一般的で、ユニタリ行列だけでなくより広いクラスの行列について何かを教えてくれる
特に、正規行列と呼ばれる行列のクラスに適用される。これにはエルミート行列も
ユニタリ行列も含まれる。これからやることは、この定理の別の表現を見ることで、今度は
半正定値行列だけに焦点を当てる。そして、密度行列について非常に興味深く、根本的に重要なことを
教えてくれることが分かるだろう。pを任意の半正定値行列とする。密度行列も
トレースが1でない半正定値行列も含む。pは半正定値なので、
正方行列でなければならない。つまりあるNに対してN×Nだ。その数Nを参照する必要があるのでNを
適切に選んだとしよう。別の言い方をすれば、pはN×Nと仮定する。この場合、定理が教えてくれることは
ψ0からψN-1と名付けるベクトルの正規直交基底が存在しなければならないということで、非負の実数
λ0からλN-1とともに、pが画面に示されているように表現できるようにする
言葉で言うと、各λkにψk⟩⟨ψkを掛けてから
0からn-1までのkについて全部足し合わせるとpが得られる。これをpのスペクトル
分解と呼ぶ。各λkはpの固有値で、各ψはpの単位固有ベクトル
その固有値に対応する。位相推定についてのレッスン7を見ると、同様の定理が
ユニタリ行列についてある。そこでは固有値が単位円上の複素数であって、非負の実数ではないが
それ以外は同じ考え方だ。これらは実際にはスペクトル定理として知られるより一般的な定理の2つの特殊なケースに過ぎない
全ての行列に使えるわけじゃない——行列がそれ自身の
共役転置と可換である必要があって、それが行列が正規であることの意味だ。でも実際に
ユニタリ行列と半正定値行列の両方、そしてより一般的にエルミート行列については常にそれが成り立つ
エルミート行列は常に実数の固有値を持つが、必ずしも非負とは限らない。これが
半正定値行列だけについてのスペクトル定理の表現で、次は密度行列について
何を教えてくれるかを見てみよう。任意のN×N密度行列に対して、常にその行列を
n個の純粋状態の凸結合として表現できるということだ。さらに、それらのn個の純粋状態を
直交するように取れる。これは定理から、線形代数の基本的な事実とともに直接導かれる
その事実とは、任意の行列の固有値の和は常にその行列のトレースに等しいということだ。言い換えると
やっていることは固有値をp0からpN-1と名前を変えて、そうしたときに
それらの固有値をN次元ベクトルにまとめると、必ず確率ベクトルになるということを観察しているだけだ。全部非負で、和は
密度行列であるρのトレースに等しく1になるからだ。かなりシンプルだが
概念的にはとても根本的だ。教えてくれることは、全ての密度行列は
どんなに複雑に見えても、問題のシステムの正規直交基底を最初に選んで
その基底から量子状態をある確率の選択に従ってランダムに選ぶことから生じる可能性がある
確率について、表面上すぐに興味深いとか重要だとわからなくても、それでいい。でもこの
事実は密度行列について推論するときに非常に頻繁に使うし、実際ある密度行列を
このように表すのは、それをよりよく理解したいときに
最初にやることが多い。例を見てみよう。以前導き出した密度行列を思い出してほしい。ランダムに
ゼロ状態とプラス状態のどちらかを確率1/2で選んだやつで、計算したとおり密度行列は
このような形になる。ゼロ状態とプラス状態は直交していないからスペクトル分解じゃない。でも
コンピューターか、こういうケースなら手計算でスペクトル分解を求めると、密度行列はこう表せる。固有値はずっと出てきているあの数で、
対応する固有ベクトルはスクリーン下に示されているものを選べる。これらのベクトルは前にも見たことがある。例えば
レッスン4のCHSHゲームの文脈でね。面白いのは、
元の表現ではこの状態はゼロ状態と
プラス状態の2つの状態から一様に選んだものだ。でも実は全く同じ密度行列が2つの純粋
状態からランダムに選ぶことでも得られる。ただしその場合は片方に非常に強く偏っていて、最初のほうが約85%で
もう一方が約15%しかない。ある意味では、元々見えていたよりも実際には
その状態に内在するランダム性はかなり少ない。単一qubitの量子状態を考えて視覚化する非常に優れた幾何学的方法があって、
ブロッホ球と呼ばれる。単一qubitにしか使えない。古典的な状態が3つ以上のシステム、
つまり2つ以上のqubitを含む場合は使えなくなる。かなり限定的だが、
それでも単一qubitの状態を考えるには素晴らしい方法だ。これはシリーズのレッスン1、単一システムの回で
導入できたかもしれないが、量子情報がどう機能するかを理解するのに必須ではなく、
密度行列との素晴らしいつながりもあるので、このレッスンに自然と馴染む。実際、
密度行列を使って効果的に導出するという、おそらく最もよく説明される方法とは
少し違うやり方で説明しようと思う。もしブロッホ球をすでに知っているなら、この説明は
最初に学んだやり方と少し違うかもしれないが、最終的にはもちろん同等のはずだ。まず
qubitの可能な純粋状態について、量子状態ベクトルで表された形から考え始めよう。
全体位相を除けば、あらゆるqubitの量子状態ベクトルは
スクリーンに示されているように表せる。正確に言うと、ThetaとPhiという2つの実数があって、
この2つの数をラジアンで表した角度として考える。最初の数Thetaは0からPiの間で、同等に言えば
0から180度の角度だ。2番目の数Phiは0から2Piの間で、0は含むが2Piは含まない。
つまり0から360度の任意の角度だ。ベクトルのゼロエントリは
Theta/2のコサインで、0から1の実数だ。特に必ず非負になる。
1エントリはe^(i*Phi)*Theta/2のサインで、
複素単位円上またはその内部の任意の複素数だ。これは常に単位ベクトルで、
つまり有効な量子状態ベクトルだ。任意のqubitの量子状態ベクトルに対して、全体位相を除いて
そのベクトルと同等なこの形のベクトルを常に見つけられる。特に与えられたベクトルに
全体位相をかけてゼロエントリを非負実数にすることは常にできる。そのエントリを与えるThetaを選んで、
1エントリに合わせてPhiを選ぶ。1エントリの絶対値は
単位ベクトルから始めたという仮定から、Theta/2のサインと必ず一致する。
ThetaとPhiが最初に使った量子状態ベクトルによって一意に決まるというわけではないが、
ほぼそうだ。0からPiの間で機能するThetaの一意な値は常に存在する。
Phiの一意な値も通常は存在するが、2つの特殊なケースではそうじゃない。具体的には標準基底状態から始めた場合、
ThetaはゼロかPiになる。どちらの場合もPhiが何であるかは実際に関係ない。
全く無関係だ。Thetaがゼロのとき、Theta/2のコサインは1でTheta/2のサインは
ゼロだ。e^(i*Phi)にゼロをかけているので、Phiが何であっても関係ない。
ThetaがPiなら今度はコサインがゼロでサインが1なので、e^(i*Phi)*|1>だが、
これらのベクトルはすべて全体位相を除いて同等だから、やはりPhiは関係ない。ただしThetaが
ゼロとPiの間に厳密にある場合は、常にPhiの一意な値が存在する。ちなみにこの
2つの特殊ケースにおけるPhiの値の縮退は、幾何学的な図を見れば完全に意味をなす。
もうすぐわかる。さて、先ほど特定したベクトルの形に関連する密度行列を計算しよう。
これはqubitの純粋状態になる。これをやるにはいつものようにベクトルに
その共役転置をかける。スクリーンには共役転置を計算して
掛け算をすることで得られる行列の式がある。すべての2x2行列と同様に、
この行列をパウリ行列の線形結合で表す一意な方法がある。
単位行列を含めてね。特にこの行列は
スクリーンに示されているようにパウリ行列の係数を選ぶことで得られる。分母に2を置いているのは
うまく整理されるからだ。これを強いられているわけじゃないが、そうできるし、そうすると便利だ。でも
この見た目の選択を除けば、ここには自由度はない。これがパウリ行列の線形結合でこの行列を得る唯一の方法だ。
なぜなら単位行列を含むパウリ行列はすべての2x2行列のベクトル空間の基底だからだ。この式の正しさを確認する一つの方法は
基本的な三角関数の恒等式を使うことで、私がどいた後に
いくつかの恒等式を見せよう。ビデオを一時停止するか
スクリーンショットを撮って、最初の密度行列の式から下の2番目の式を導けるか試してみてほしい。要約すると、qubitの任意の純粋状態は
密度行列として表されるとき、スクリーンに示されているようなパウリ行列の線形結合として書ける。
ThetaをゼロからpiまでFを0から2 piまでの範囲でスクリーンに描くと、以前とまったく同じ
縮退があることに気づく——Thetaがゼロかpiのときにfiが無関係になるという縮退だ。今回は実際に
それをより明確に見ることができる。なぜならS of thetaはその2つのケースでゼロになり、それ以外の場合はそうならないからだ。指摘する価値があるのは、
この式ではThetaがサインとコサイン関数の引数として現れており、元の量子状態
ベクトル版のようなTheta over 2ではないということだ。これは三角法の恒等式を使ったからで、最初の3つは基本的に
いわゆる2倍角の公式の変形だ。つまり角度が実質的に2倍になる。そしてついに
ブロッホ球自体について話す準備が整った。密度行列の式の分子にある、単位行列以外のパウリ
行列の3つの係数に注目しよう。つまり分母の2は無視する。
また単位行列も無視する。なぜならその係数は変化しないからだ。これは、
その係数が表現している行列のトレースによって決まり、密度行列のトレースは常に
1だからだ。今度はx、y、zとラベル付けされた3つの軸が
いわゆる右手の法則に従って向けられていると想像し、3つの係数に一致する座標を持つ点を考えよう。明確にしておくと、これは
座標が常に実数である通常の三次元空間のことだ。
x座標は式の分子にあるシグマXパウリ行列の係数に対応する。これは密度
行列がエルミートであるため常に実数だ。YとZも同様だ。得られるこの点は
常に単位球面上にある——つまり半径が
1の球面だ。特に、正のz軸が球面と交わる点から始めて
北極と考えられる点から正のx軸の方向にthetaの角度だけ回転し、次に
正のy軸方向つまり東方向へfiの角度だけ回転したときに得られる点だ。この文脈ではThetaは
極角と呼ばれる——極から始まるから覚えやすい。Fは方位角と呼ばれる。
この2つの角度を合わせると単位球面上の点の球座標を表す。もし
望むなら、半径を変化させて三次元空間内の任意の点を表すこともできるが、ここでは
半径が1の単位球面上の点に焦点を当てている。Thetaは緯度と考えることもできるが、赤道から
±90°ではなく北極から南極へ0°から180°の範囲で変化する。そしてFは経度を表す——
基本的に本初子午線を正の
x軸と交わる子午線として定義する。ちなみに私のように緯度と経度のどちらがどちらか混乱しがちな人には、
経度は長い方の区間——2 piに対応すると覚えると助かるかもしれない。piではなく。
とにかく、qubit状態ベクトルから単位球面上で得られる点は、この方法で座標を考えることによって
ψに対応する量子状態のブロッホ球表現だ。全体の
三次元単位球面についてこのように考えるとブロッホ球が得られる。幾何学的には通常の三次元空間における単位
球面に過ぎないが、実際これがqubit
状態の幾何学だ。ここには完全な一対一対応がある——qubitの純粋状態はそれぞれ球面上の一意な点に対応する。
そして球面上の各点はグローバル位相を除いて一意なqubit状態を表す。量子状態
ベクトルを扱うとき、この対応は別の名前で呼ばれることもある。例えばポアンカレ球と呼ばれることもある。
しかし量子情報の文脈では一般的にブロッホ球と呼ばれる。fiの角度の縮退がかなり明確に見えるようになったことに気づくだろう——
経度は北極と南極では意味を持たないからだ。でも極以外では
地球上の各点は緯度と経度で一意な座標を持つ。ここでも同じことが起きている。これがブロッホ球の
一般的な仕組みだ。次にqubit状態のいくつかの具体例と
ブロッホ球上の位置を見てみよう。まず標準基底から始めよう。これらは
零状態では極角Thetaがゼロ、1状態ではpiのときに得られる点だ。これがすでに述べた
方位角fiが無関係になる2つのケースだ。対応する密度行列をパウリ行列の線形結合として表すこともできる。どちらの方法でも、これら2つの状態がブロッホ球の北極と
南極に対応することがわかる。零状態が上で、1状態が
下だ。次にブロッホ球上のプラス状態とマイナス状態を見つけよう。ここでも
量子状態ベクトルか密度行列のどちらで考えることもできる。量子状態ベクトルの場合、今度は零成分を1/√2にするために極角Thetaがpi
/ 2でなければならない。方位角Fはプラス状態では
ゼロでなければならない——プラス状態では1の成分が正だからだ。マイナス状態ではpiつまり180°でなければならない
——その場合は負だからだ。つまりこれら2つの点は
ブロッホ球の赤道上にある。プラス状態は正のx軸が球面と交わる点で、マイナス状態は反対側の
負のx軸が球面と交わる点にある。同様に、対応する密度行列のパウリ行列表現からも
YとZ座標がともにゼロで、x座標が正と負の
1であることがわかる。別の例はプラスI・マイナスI基底だ。これはプラス・マイナス基底に似ているが、1の成分に
虚数単位Iを掛けている点が異なる。プラスI状態はこのレッスンで先ほど見た。マイナスI状態も
同様の方法で定義される。極角Thetaはプラス・マイナス状態と同じく
pi / 2だ。今度は方位角FをIとマイナスIが得られるように選ぶ必要がある——1とマイナス1ではなく。
pi / 2と3 pi / 2がそれを実現する正しい選択だ。ここでも
これらの状態の密度行列による記述を見ることができる。前の2つの例に非常に似ているが、今度はZやXの代わりにパウリY行列が使われている。
つまりブロッホ球上では、これら2つの状態はy軸が
球面と交わる点に位置する。少し整理すると、今述べた6つの状態が
互いにどう関係しているかがより明確にわかる。もう一つだけ例を挙げよう——というか例のクラスを——
先ほどとレッスン4で登場したqubit状態ベクトルを考えよう。零成分がある実数alphaに対してcosine of alphaで、1の成分が
要素はalphaのSだ。ちなみにalphaの値はゼロからPiの間に限定して考えていい。なぜなら
他のalphaの値を使っても、alphaがこの範囲にある場合と全体位相を除いて同等なベクトルが得られるからだ
これらの状態に対応する密度行列を、Pauli行列の線形結合として表現して計算すると
画面に表示されているような式が得られる。その計算過程はここでは示していないが、それが
実際に得られる結果だ。そしてわかるのは、これらの状態が「大円」と呼ばれるものを形成するということで、その大円は
極点を通っている。具体的には、alphaがゼロの時は北極から始まり、本初子午線を下っていき
alphaがpi/2の時に南極に到達し、そしてalphaがpi/2からPiの範囲になると球の反対側を通って北極に戻る
これは全て理にかなっている。理由の一つ目は、これらが実数ベクトルなので虚部は常にゼロだということ、そして
二つ目は、角度alphaがBloch球上で実質的に二倍になるということだ。これは
二倍角の公式を使えば説明できる。Bloch球がqubitの純粋状態に対して非常に美しい幾何学的表現を与えることを見てきた
球面上の各点がqubitのユニークな純粋状態に一対一で対応しており、逆もまた
然りだ。Blochボールと言う場合、Bloch球面上の全ての点に加えて、その内部の点も
含んでいる。Blochボールの内部の点もqubit状態に対応している
具体的には純粋状態でない状態だ。つまり、密度行列で表現できるがqubit状態ベクトルでは表現できないqubit状態だ
Blochボールの基本的な側面として、内部の点が非純粋状態を表す方法については、
Blochボール内の点の凸結合が密度行列の凸結合に対応するということがある
直感的に言えば、これはBlochボールの内部においても幾何学が完璧に機能し続けることを意味している
いくつか例を見てみよう。まずBlochボールの中心点から始める。これは
完全混合状態を表している。完全混合状態はゼロ状態と1状態を平均することで得られる。これは
球の中心が北極と南極のちょうど中間にあるという事実と一致している。実際、plus状態とminus状態、plus I状態とminus I状態のような任意の対蹠点の中間にもある
Bloch球における対蹠点は常に直交する純粋状態に対応している
これが示しているのは、完全混合状態は常に任意の二つの直交する純粋qubit状態の平均として書けるということだ
これを見る別の方法として、完全混合状態のPauli行列表現について考えてみよう。これを成立させるためには
単位行列以外の三つのPauli行列全ての係数をゼロに設定しなければならない。だから対応するBlochボール内の点は
原点のちょうど中心にある。ちなみに密度行列のPauli行列表現について考えることで
Blochボールの点の凸結合が密度行列の凸結合に対応することがかなり明確になる
密度行列の平均や加重平均を取って、Pauli行列の線形結合で全てを表現すると
当然、対応する点を平均していることになる。なぜならすべてが
三つの係数において線形だからだ。もう一つの例として、ゼロ状態とplus状態の平均を考えよう
これはレッスンの前半で見たものだ。密度行列表現を計算したが、それが画面に
表示されている。そして点はゼロとplus状態の中間、Blochボールの内部にあることがわかる
また、このスペクトル分解に基づいて密度行列を別の方法で表現できることも見た
これも図や前の例と一致している。これでBloch球とBlochボールの
議論は終わりだ。よく聞かれるのは、三つ以上の古典状態を持つ系に対してBloch球やBlochボールがあるのかということだ
残念ながら、答えは「あまりない」だ。系の量子状態については常に
Blochボールに似た幾何学的な観点で考えることができ、実数ベクトル空間の凸体が得られる
しかし三つ以上の古典状態がある場合、それは球形にはならない。例えば
ちょうど三つの古典状態、略してqutritの場合、八次元空間の凸体が得られる
しかしその凸体の端点、つまりqutritの純粋量子状態に対応する部分は
四次元にしかならない。八次元空間の中の四次元多様体を取って、それを何とかシュリンクラップして凸体を
得るというのが視覚化できて、qutritsについて考える助けになるなら、まあそれはそれでいい。興味深い
考え方ではあるが、ボールではなく、それよりずっと複雑だ。レッスンの最後の部分では
複数の系に対して密度行列がどう機能するかについて簡単に説明する。密度行列は複数の系の状態を表現できる
これは量子状態ベクトルと全く同様の方法で機能する。特に、量子情報の簡略化された定式化と同様に
複数の系を一つの複合系として見ることができる
今回は、複数の系の状態を表す密度行列の行と列の両方が
個々の系の古典状態集合のデカルト積に対応している。例えば
四つのBell状態の密度行列表現を考えることができる。これは他の量子状態ベクトルの場合と全く同様に
レッスンの前半で得られたもので、状態ベクトルにその共役転置を掛けることで得られる。結果は画面に表示されている
本質的に概念レベルでは全く新しいことはないが、複数の系に対して密度行列でできる
新しいことが間もなく出てくる。独立性と
相関の概念は量子状態ベクトルから密度行列に引き継がれる。特に
密度行列のテンソル積は系間の独立性を表す。量子状態ベクトルで使ったのと同じ用語を使う
例えば、系Xが状態rowで準備され、系Yが
独立に状態Sigmaで準備された場合、ペアXYの状態は
rowとSigmaのテンソル積で与えられる。これを積状態と呼び、二つ以上の系に自然に一般化される
積状態として表現できない密度行列は系間の相関を表している
その部分は量子状態ベクトルと似ているが、密度行列を使う場合、二つの系だけでも
異なる種類の相関が生じ得ることがわかっている
対照的に、量子状態ベクトルで持てる相関の種類は実質一つしかない
それがエンタングルメントだ。別の言い方をすると、量子状態ベクトルでは相関とエンタングルメントは同義だが
密度行列ではそれは成り立たない。ここはもっと興味深い。例えば、
密度行列で古典的な相関状態を記述できる。これはAliceとBobの間で共有された古典的なランダム
ビットを表す密度行列の例だ。二人は常に同じ古典的な状態、0か1を持ち、確率は
それぞれ1/2だ。これはエンタングルメント状態ではない。エンタングルメントは非古典的なものだが、
これは相関状態だ。もう一つの例は、量子状態のアンサンブルという概念と結びついている。
これは有限集合の量子状態上の確率分布として考えられる。特に、
M個の密度行列ρ_0からρ_があり、それらはすべて特定のシステムの可能な状態を表している
とともに、それぞれを引き出す確率がある。これらの密度行列の加重平均を計算したいなら、
凸結合を取ることで計算できるが、それでは個々の状態が何なのか、あるいは
確率が何なのかはわからない。代わりにできること、そしてときには非常に有用なのは、密度
行列をここに示す形式で考えることだ。これは二つのシステムの状態で、最初のシステムは古典的な
状態をM個の選択肢それぞれに持ち、M個の積状態の加重平均を取る。第一システムの状態は
常に古典的で、本質的に第二システムのm個の状態のどれに対応するかをラベル付けしている。
なぜこのような状態を考えたいのかが明確でなくても大丈夫だ。これはただの
相関の種類の例であり、第一システムは常に古典的で、第二システムは量子
状態になり得る。相関状態の可能性の第三のカテゴリーは、いわゆる分離可能な
状態の集合だ。簡単に言えば、これらは積状態の凸結合であり、本質的に現在の量子
状態を表し、システム間の相関はすべて古典的な相関だ。このような状態を考える一つの方法は、
数Kを確率的に選び、そのKの選択に依存できる量子状態で二つの
システムを独立に準備するということだ。この形式の状態について最も興味深いのは、
これが数学的な意味でエンタングルメントを定義する方法だということだ。特に、エンタングルメントは
分離可能性の欠如として定義される。つまり、密度行列があってそれをこのような形式で表現できない場合、
定義上それはエンタングルしている。これはレッスン4でも触れたが、ここではもう少し
詳しく述べる。ちなみに、ある密度行列がエンタングルした状態を表しているかどうかを判断するのは、コンピューターを使っても
非常に難しい場合がある。数学的・計算的に見ると、エンタングルメントは
実はかなり複雑だ。レッスンの冒頭で、密度行列でできる非常に重要なことがあると述べた。
それは、他のシステムと相関していたりエンタングルしていたりする場合でも、システムの孤立した部分の状態を
記述できることだ。この文脈では「縮約状態」という用語がよく使われる。簡単な例として、
ebitを形成する個々のqubitの縮約状態を計算してみよう。正確に言うと、
AliceとBobがebitを共有しているとしよう。AliceはqubitAを持ち、BobはqubitBを持ち、この二つのqubitは合わせてΦ+
状態にある。ここで取り上げる問いは、AliceのqubitAの状態が孤立した場合
どうなるかだ。もちろん、Bobのqubitについても同じ問いを立てられるが、この問いへの答えがわかれば、それも簡単に答えられる。
さて、AliceのqubitはBobのqubitとエンタングルしているので、孤立した状態を記述できないと
言いたくなるかもしれない。それがAの状態を記述したり考えたりすることを何らかの形で禁じているかのように。
しかしこれは誤りだ。確かに、Aの状態を量子状態ベクトルで記述することはできない。
後で見るように純粋状態ではないからだ。しかしすべてのシステムは、他のシステムとエンタングルしていようとなかろうと、
任意の時点で密度行列で記述できる状態を持つ。この問いへの答えを理解するための思考実験として、
Bobが自分のqubitを持って星へ旅立ち、二度と連絡が取れなくなったとしよう。
しかし、その途中のどこかで彼が自分のqubitに標準基底測定を行うことにしたとしよう。
その場合、二つの可能な結果を得る確率を計算できるし、それぞれの結果に対してAの状態がどうなるかもわかる。
それらはこの表にまとめられている。特に、確率1/2でAはゼロ状態に残り、
確率1/2でAはイチ状態に残る。これはレッスンの前半で述べたように、Aを完全混合状態に残す。したがってそれが
この問いへの答えだ。ここで異議を唱えるかもしれない。これはBobが
自分のqubitを測定することにしたという事実に依存しており、彼がそうするという仮定がこの答えに至った話の一部だと。しかし
Bobが測定する頃には光年も離れていれば、彼が行うことは何であれ、Aliceが
自分のqubitで行うかもしれない実験に何ら影響を与えることはできない。そうでなければ光速より速い
通信が可能になってしまう。だからAliceのqubitは、Bobが測定するかどうかにかかわらず
完全混合状態にある。ここで明確にしておきたいのは、縮約状態の概念とその定義方法は、相対性理論や
光速より速い通信の不可能性には実際には依存していないということだ。これはただ直感的な言葉で説明しようとしているだけだ。
実際には数学的な定義があり、それを少し後でより一般的な文脈で見ることになる。それはこの答えと
一致しており、光速より速い通信の不可能性とも一致する。また、
我々が知っている量子情報と一致する他の定義は存在しない。では、縮約状態をより一般的に
考えてみよう。システムAとBのペアがあり、必ずしもqubitでなくてもよく、合わせて純粋状態にあるとしよう。
量子状態ベクトルsで表されるとする。また、システムAの縮約状態に注目する。そのために
システムBの古典的な状態を考えることが役に立つ。γをこの
Bの古典的な状態の集合とする。以前、このシリーズのレッスン2で述べたように、
各BとΓに対して、画面に示されているsの表現が正しくなるような
ベクトルf_bの一意のコレクションがある。
これは正しい。特に、これらのベクトルの単純な公式がある。ベクトルsに、システムAに対応する単位行列と
関心のある任意のBのブラBのテンソル積を掛けるだけだ。
ここでやっていることは基本的に、システムBに対して標準基底測定を行った場合に何が起こるかを計算するための準備だ。
Bに対して標準基底測定を行う——これはシリーズの
レッスン2で扱った内容だ。実際にBの標準基底測定を行うと、各結果が得られる確率は
対応するベクトル5bのユークリッドノルムの二乗に等しくなる。そして特定の
結果Bが得られたとき、ベクトル5Bを正規化してaの
状態を決定する。少し前のebitの例と同じ推論に従うと、画面に示した式が
aの縮約状態を密度行列として与える。ちなみに分母のノルムの二乗は
正規化ベクトルとその共役転置の積から来ており、ユークリッドノルムが分母に
2回現れる。ユークリッドノルムの二乗は打ち消し合い、かなりシンプルな
式が残る。実際、5Bの公式を代入すると——これはすべてのBに対して成立する——aの縮約
状態を、最初に出発した純粋状態、すなわちcsaiの密度行列表現で表す式が得られる
brasaiというわけだ。これが複合系ABが純粋状態sighから始まると仮定したときの
系aの縮約状態の公式だ。ただしこの公式はより一般的にも使える。特に
abの状態が何らかの密度行列rowで与えられる場合を考えよう。それはK SI braiの形をとることもあるが
必ずしもそうである必要はない。線形性からほぼ直ちに、aの縮約状態は
純粋状態の場合と同じ公式で決まる。ただし密度行列rowを
任意に代入する。略記法として、この縮約状態を使用中の
密度行列の名前——ここではRow——に注目する系を示す添字を付けて表すのが一般的だ。添字aが付いたrowは
複合系が状態rowにあるときのaの縮約状態を意味する。上付き添字が
下付き添字の代わりに使われることもある。単なる個人の好みで、意味は同じだ。
簡単のために系aに注目してきたが、系Bの縮約状態も
同様に求められる。公式を自然な形に適応させるだけで、すべて対称だ。
本質的にAとBの役割を入れ替えるだけで、特に和はBではなくaの古典状態の集合上で取られる
画面の公式では、aの古典状態の集合を
Sigmaと呼んでいる。これはすべて3つ以上の系にかなり素直に一般化できる。たとえば3つの
系a、b、cが集合的に密度行列rowで記述される状態にある場合、
ここに示した公式でペアaの縮約状態を求められるし、第3の系単体の状態も
2番目の公式で求められる。他の組み合わせも考えられるし、好きなだけ多くの系に一般化できる。和は常に
無視される系の古典状態の集合上で取られ、パターンは常に同じだ——密度
行列を恒等行列のテンソル積と標準基底状態に対応するbraとketで挟む形になる。
レッスンの締めくくりとして、今カバーした定義についてもう少し述べておく。密度
行列上の縮約状態を記述する操作には名前があり、部分トレースと呼ばれる。2つの系AとBに対して
Bに関する部分トレースとaに関する部分トレースは画面に定義されている通りだ。これらはまったく同じ
公式で、少し前に見たものだ。今はrowの関数として考えて名前を
付けているだけだ。名前はトレースに似ているが、添字があってどの系が除去されるかを示す
つまりどの系の古典状態の集合上で和が取られ、braとketで
挟まれているかを示す。たとえばBのrowの部分トレースを取ると——第1の公式で記述される——
bはトレースアウトされると言う。aも同様だ。直感的にはシステムを
トレースアウトするとは、それを捨てる、あるいは単に無視するということだ。部分
トレースの定義の一つはこれだ。もう一つの等価な方法は、これらの写像が
右に示した公式を満たす唯一の線形写像だと言うことだ。具体的には2つの行列MとNのテンソル積があって
第1の系に関する部分トレースを取ると、第1の行列Mのトレースに
第2の行列を掛けたものが得られる。第2の系でトレースを取ると条件は対称になる。部分トレースを
計算するすべての行列がこのようなテンソル積であるわけではないが、どの行列も
テンソル積の線形結合として表せる。そしてこれらが線形であるという事実と合わせてこれらの条件から部分トレースが決まる
これが部分トレースと呼ばれる理由だ。この等価な定義は
元の公式の代わりによく使えるのでかなり便利だ。それを示す例を見てみよう。
2つのqubitのペアを考えよう。aは画面に示された密度行列の状態にある。
これは相関状態の例で、aはゼロ状態かいち状態にあり、それぞれ
確率1/2だ。つまりaは古典的と考えられる。aがゼロ状態なら
Bもゼロ状態で、aがいち状態ならBはplus状態だ。aの縮約状態を知りたければ
Bをトレースアウトする。等価な定義の第2の公式と線形性を使えば
かなり簡単に計算できる。特にk0 bra 0のトレースは1で、K plus bra
plusのトレースも同様だ。そのテンソル因子は消え、完全混合状態が残る。同様にBの
縮約状態はaをトレースアウトして計算できる。今回は第1のテンソル因子にトレースを行うので
等価な定義の第1の公式を使う。1/2 * ket 0 bra 0に1/2 * ket
plus bra Plusを足したものが残る。つまり以前何度か出てきたのと同じ密度行列だ。
第1の定義の公式を使っても同じ結果が得られるが、こちらの方がずっと簡単だ。これはすべて3つ以上の
系に一般化できるが、このビデオではここで止めて自分で考えてもらうことにする。以上でこのレッスンは終わりだ。
このレッスンでは密度行列を導入しその基本的な仕組みを説明した。またBloch球も
取り上げたほか、様々な種類の相関と系の縮約状態の概念についても議論した。次の
レッスンにも参加してほしい。次のレッスンはchannelについて——密度行列から密度行列への線形写像で、
系に対する操作を記述するものだ。それではまた
次回に